you have made a lot of movies about
families but you haven't made a lot of
movies where people are both parent and
child of parent was that period in time
particularly important to you when you
have a kid and you're also a kid of
somebody else's yeah that was I in
retrospectively when I look I think a
big part of what I was looking at when I
started writing this that that and and
that you you you you the sort of what it
means to be a child as a grown-up and
and and of course if you're then your
parent you know starts to regress
naturally you know then you become a
parent to your parent and of course then
it gets confusing and and so you know
putting that in this family and sort of
exploring family mythologies to and sort
of how families kind of create their own
rules and ideas for how you know in what
success is what failure is what you know
is good what's bad and how you you know
you realize when you you know grow up
that you've internalized these things
like it in some ways it's it's no longer
even about the parent it's about the
parent that's now inside you and that I
was trying to find a way to you know
dramatize that it's a take what is
essentially psychology and make it you
know make it action how much time do you
have to talk to work to talk with Noah
about where you got as characters to
this place is there a lot of time for
rehearsal and conversation and Adams
nodding so yes yes absolutely and what
were the questions that you had for Noah
about about Danny oh I all of us we had
plenty of time to sit and talk to no
first of all when I read the script I
like all of us we couldn't I just
couldn't believe how great every word
was and every character and the story
and meant a lot to me that Noah worked
as hard as he did and and gave us this
material and just just all of us would
talk to Noah more and more about our
characters and go deeper and deeper in
backstory and find out
everything that led to this this time
something that's really unusual with
working with Noah is you know he's
ridiculously generous and he builds in a
massive amount of time before you start
filming to work and so we all got a lot
of time one-on-one with him to go very
deep into our characters but then he
gave us several weeks to be together and
to sort of organically find our family
together and we also got to spend a lot
of time with the script itself because
of the way he writes because it's so
specific to each individual but then
there's a family rhythm in the language
we really needed to spend time with the
words together and he gave us that time
Dustin what is it like when you're
workmen though it because he is so exact
about language and about dialogue what
is the relationship that the actor has
and interpreting that dialogue if the
dialogue isn't going to change
fundamentally from what Noah's written I
think the first meeting we had and we we
met here in LA for a couple of months
sometimes two three times a week and I
think I think when I read this we read
the script together playing different
parts and at the office and I think the
first thing I said was so do we get to
improvise much and he didn't answer and
he didn't move his head so I got the
point but then I thought squid in the
whale I said but that's improvised so
much of that he says no and I said are
you saying word-for-word
he says yes and then when we finally
started shooting we realize it was worse
than word-for-word
what's worse well there was an assistant
charming a gal who sat next to him with
the script and come up to us sometimes
and say that's not a period that's three
dots
and you know to clarify it though it's
it's a movie that runs about an hour of
50 minutes and it's a hundred and
seventy five pages Oh usually that's 110
15 pages so there was a rhythm that we
had to you know hold and once we got
that it helped us the first draft was
220 but there were 70 pages on pagina
man got the DVD you'll see all that
extra stuff great someone I asked you
about
pajama man you have actually had the
chance to see some student films at Bard
College with this play accurately I must
say I have a lot of friends at Bard and
I got to watch some of their films and
it's it's very surprisingly very
accurate and you had a lot of naked
people running through woods not really
much of a plot yeah but one thing that I
think is important is that Danny and one
other characters watch your daughter's
film nobody's judging it nobody's saying
what is this they're just saying this is
who she is this is what her art
represents nobody's condemning it or
judging it and that feels like that's
very important to you know as a
screenwriter and Dan it's important to
your character as well
those are good dailies because it's we
hadn't didn't have the movie yet so
they're all watching the computer screen
and it's me reading the description
off-camera and cracking myself up while
I'm doing it while they're all trying to
like you really paid do it all so yeah
and then I would just laugh look anyway
sorry I'd be like now she's peeing in a
urinal
now she's but but then there's also
nothing more difficult than trying to
shoot a student film with a professional
film group it's just yeah they're just
people are freaking out about how are we
gonna do this you know the the cape what
materials the cape made us I just
imagine that we're all students here
maybe we just wing it but it was both
like they were both like
over prepared and underprepared it was
like though that was much harder than
shooting it the Museum of Modern Art
there's also something that happens to
Jean that I would say in the last given
the last week of news plays differently
play plays differently in this building
where a day ago yesterday we know who
was voted out of the Academy how does
that scene play differently in your mind
and does it actually in some ways
validate what it is that she is talking
about having happened
that's injury and he's clearly talking
about the molestation that I talked
about by Paul Edelstein my father's
friend and it's it's interesting because
of the current events
it does take on a sudden different
resonance for us all which is
unavoidable but you know I think you
scratch the surface of any woman and
she'll tell you a handful of those
stories it's just not a complicated
unusual thing I ride the subway in New
York on a regular basis and I have men
jerking off at me I mean it's just the
deal so the fact that it suddenly risen
to the level of like real huge
engagement I think is terrific
I think it's wonderful how Noah writes
about it in this movie because it's in
it's inconvenience because he didn't
touch me it's it's inconvenient and it
gets brushed away and the tennis game is
played and I'm sent back to my camp
where I'm a counselor and you know it's
it's um it's a wonderful thing that's
come up at this moment and it's
interesting how resonant it is and how
many people are stopping me and talking
about it and even before the current
affairs came up we did a sag thing where
the guy in the audience who had worked
with people who had been sexually abused
was asking me about it because because
it was so honestly portrayed in the
movie from his experience working with
people and so I say all that just that
yes it's under a
magnifying lens at this moment but it's
it's just a story so many people have to
tell Adam and grace I want to ask you a
little bit about Danny and Eliza as a
parent who's about to send a kid off to
college the idea of the way in which you
two get along and what you see in each
other is really beautiful and I think as
a parent I can aspire to want to have a
relationship with a child like that can
you talk a little bit about what you
talked about in how your bond as father
and daughter came together because we
don't know the backstory we don't know
how they've become so close and how they
get along so well what did you talk
about with with each other and with Noah
I don't know about backstory but that
was a a relationship that really drew me
to the script and Elijah's love for her
family and especially her father and how
she does go off to college but doesn't
see it as an excuse to to have this
independence and to get away from her
family she can't help but you don't want
to know what's going on with him and
make sure he's okay and I thought that
was so beautiful but as a backstory you
know I was just good to be we were we
got close immediately just very what are
we sang and we sang that song we did a
lot of rehearsals on that song when we
first met and then we did more and more
just hanging out and going over the
script and I did love the openness of
their relationship and the the freedom
that they felt with each other to say
what's on their minds and there was and
it didn't feel very parent II felt you
know the I am her father and the movie
but they feel like very good friends and
you know the fact that she can show me
her movies and you know you know just
even even the free talking about her
drinking and it's just very light and
very that's what my wife always tells me
with my kids just to make sure that I
just stay light with them so they never
hide anything they seem like they they
always these two are very just just good
good friends and that's that's nice for
that's nice for a relationship well is
they also the song did do a lot for them
I think even and rehearsing that because
in the way the movie you know there's so
much talking in the movie and so clearly
and also so little communication and
it's sort of like where does the
communication happen and I it does
happen in the songs I mean it's like I
mean they I mean they have a they
they're able to talk to each other those
characters but the the songs you know
the the Myron Byron song is one of the
sweeter moments between Harold and you
know in the way Dustin comes in sort of
like slaps his shoulder you know like
there's something very moving to me
about even just that gesture you know
that he can't quite participate but he's
doing it and and that sort of that where
the family finds that you know it's
watching baseball games it's what you
know it's it's stuff that's outside of
that I'm you know so I do think the song
did a lot to just even rehearsing it